[Music]
and so here we have Zelda she is an
adult female howler monkey who came to
us about eight months ago and Zelda was
one of the worst victims of electric
shock on the powerline that we have ever
seen over 50% of her body was covered in
burns her skin was peeling off all the
prefer was singed she must have gone up
in a ball of flames she couldn't feel or
move half of her tail we thought her
hand was gonna have to be amputated but
through hours and days and months of
really really intensive care we were
finally able to get her to turn that
corner and as you can see now she's
really a completely different monkey all
of her skin has grown back she started
using her tail again and that's the last
thing that we were waiting on this is
always the best day of an animal's time
here is the day we get to release them
back into the wild so she's showing a
very appropriate fear of humans right
now which is excellent that's exactly
what we want to see we don't want them
to come to us easily we don't want them
to feel comfortable around us because
when they go out into the wild that
makes them unsafe she just grabbed me
with the tail really strong so that's an
excellent sign she's ready to go
[Music]
so we brought Zelda back to the area
where she was found we always want to
try to release animals back into their
original home range so she'll know where
the food is where to find shelter if she
wants to reunite with her original troop
she has the ability to do so and we're
releasing her right next to this almond
early-day lamont ano the mountain almond
tree which is one of her favorite kinds
of leaves
as soon as we left she went up to that
almond tree that we had next to her and
was hanging upside down by her tail
completely using the tail which is
exactly what we want to see and eating
from the almond tree which is her
favorite kind of leaves so that was
really amazing to see we wish her well
she she's gonna be great on the wild
[Music]